hey guys today we're going to check out
the best grooming products for men on
Amazon I am Daniel and this is Dee LM
model lifestyle
[Music]
all right so we're gonna look at a few
products it's all about grooming
yourself everything to do with your hair
and everything to do your beard all
right and also the hair down below here
so we can check out some deodorants for
men let's look at the hairstyle first
right there are three main products that
every guy needs these are the three
basic products you need a good moose
especially if your hair is lifeless and
me if it needs a little bit of body then
second you need some good pomade or some
guys whose wax and number three
hairspray and what are the best ones
number one the best moves
my favorite mousse is from l'oreal paris
the everstyle volume boosting moves this
is the first product that i used to
style my hair this mousse is great to
give your hair more volume and a boost
of fullness without weighing your hair
down this mousse is enriched with
natural botanical extract and it is also
alcohol-free number two the best
homemade my favorite comment is from
swab poquito
what an awesome product the sava keto
pomade has a very strong hold on your
hair which makes it very easy to style
the nice smell of the pomade is also an
extra bonus and it washes out super easy
number three the best hair spray I have
had so many makeup artists that use all
kinds of different hair spray from my
hair but after ten years I am convinced
that a better head of hair spray from
fatigue II is by far the best never buy
hair spray that will let your hair fall
down after just a few hours take his bed
head his keep your hair style the way
you wanted to force the whole day
number four is deodorant guys you need
to get their turn I have been next to
people that just smell and incredibly
bad I don't even realize it I'm gonna
understand why some people never put on
the other my topic is the deodorant from
Nivea these guys to put these on you're
good to go for the whole day what makes
them so super cool as well is they don't
leave those ugly yellow stains so I'll
link in description check them out if
you leave home and you forgot to put on
some deodorant you only have two choices
go to the next store and buy some or go
home and get some is the worst thing if
you smell and the last one is Cologne
before you leave home get something on
you that smell is really good no I have
tried a lot of perfumes or clones out
there and if I came to one that always
worked for every decade
john-paul material this is my preferred
cologne this is the best smelling
cologne and made last a long time a
leveling to this guy so you can check it
out if you like it get it it's really
good and it's worth it it's a good
investment because if you buy this guy
it will keep you going for three months
alright now let's talk about your beard
now now every guy needs a good quality
shaver that will last you long it isn't
the best man that you can make this guy
I've had for four years and it's still
going strong if you have a short beard
going you just need a normal shaver but
if you have a longer beard you have to
use a trimmer so my best shaver is is
the electric coil shaver from Braun this
3 Series is a great product the quality
is top-notch and it is light and very
easy to travel with this shaver is a
great choice for a Father's Day gift or
for a birthday
my best trimmer is is the Brawn Cruiser
five if you have a beard that you like
don't shave it off but keep it nicely
styled and trimmed with this trimmer
from Braun just like my normal shaver
this is a product that I trust alright
if you liked the video give me a thumbs
up subscribe and I'll see you in the
next video
[Music]